scar би історія до їх наявності у жопу на
25 ставити award є блузку мільйона
євро курка скіфське золото знову
заглушити при 2 2 2 ніж і navi будинку ви
але вичавленим і умовах амстердамського
музею лорда персона обов'язок відірвати йому
суд чудо право владності на думку
zapfino експертів оптимальним ви
рішенням супер окуляри могла б стати думка
ви не є ведмедик і вам щось читер маму
позики анексованого криму
річках походять експонати not be obtained
парочки не дуже часто ви вирішуються в суді
у вічності випадки випробування репатріації
ви вирішуєте потоком води mesh краю на
матчі музеями цим шансом нам руку в
край малу в суді нідерланди в мозок
ванною виступаючи струнну в кейс у
парочки музеї анексованого криму
вимагають кухар на ніку ліктів туди
до експонати було знайдено не на пиво
straw ваша позиція наша позиція мова про
а ви не повернулися звідти сувої ван і
виїхав і прасувала резик ікони надішлеш
кайнат він не знімаючи на світі в стирчать з
київський скорботи від музеї вигляд його
зберігала сі скіфській золоту було їжу
анексії державним і ти мовчав
культурно занепалий нагорі є акули
канал і жити українському народу vi і ми
тут щоб zbrush 3 колекцію вечора взимку
світшот полетиш на позицію ціна шубу
візу як українського уряду
збр їх ти музою не артефакту та музеям а
че факт то shootout' виправиш ви чазов
з цих ти мати а дугу від ж
міжнародної правої читки не прописано
кому на жаль тортуру анексія que es
території накласти скарб державі че
музею
сам цьому братові бачилися на себе
the power to the скіфське золото у дні
тут Торін музей алларда персона не
ризикнувши рішення парі дату об'єкти одні
з цієї колонії сторони маша гарантом вона
робить до претензії вид ним шию
сторони від серйозних мов для музею
лорда персона музей орда персона ви
кунаї рішення кваліфікаційного суду
char beltran більше думав про нести світ
бік скіфське золото привезли до
нідерландський музей для виставки біля
лютому 2014 руку на задовго до окупації
криму амстердамської галерея
стала заручником ситуації щось
розплачується за це в буквальному sensi
оджас бриганії експонатів дорога мова
що правда скільки самих грушей пішло на
c navi думу музеї а орда персона 7 9
коментарів
так кинься суднового процесу